Oh
she puts it down
I immediately hear there's seven
security guards in black with machine
guns and I go what who's the asshole now
this is not happening
I'm your host Roy Wood jr. we all have
that special woman in our life the one
we like to put up on a pedestal finger
sandwiches boy
oh thank you mom go make it rain
[Applause]
[Music]
now make sure you separate the ones from
the five no no I gotta pick up some
money if I rate the Beals that's my
boy and a pleasure to share microphone
with it you know it from her comedy
special bothering Jesus Kathleen
[Music]
my mom was turning 65 and the way my
parents have drank and smoked you know
65 I thought this could be the last big
one so I said I mean there'd been no
indications but I own 70 vme long shot
and I said well you're turning 65 is
there anything you really want and she
said yeah I've never left the country
and I want to go to Paris in Rome I said
wow your dad should do that she goes no
no your father won't go because he's
still really mad about the war but he
wasn't even in a war she goes no it was
their behavior he's never gonna get over
the Italians went bad and the French
wouldn't do their part and he's not
gonna go I said are you serious like he
will not she goes oh he won't go that's
all right well I'll go I'll I'll go with
you and I have six siblings I go ask
whoever you want and then we'll let's
get four that's fine for this trip so
she said alright she asked my younger
sister who's 10 years younger than me
and diabolically opposite blond-haired
blue-eyed the happiest human just a
yellow lab running at you're just like
theirs we have nothing in common except
we're sisters and then she invited my
sister-in-law who is a perfect planner I
go great so Amy my sister is named Kate
yes we have the same name that's a
different joke I won't go into but Amy
the sister-in-law
that's the one I'm counting on great
because my mom has a bad knee so she's
me walking slowly one of her teeth is
kind of falling out we don't know if
it's gonna make it this could be a
show but if I have help it's gonna be
fine well my mom called before we left
and she said your sister-in-law canceled
so I invited Daisy
I go Daisy that your neighbor she goes
yeah Daisy I go how old is Daisy she was
what she's 79
but she does yoga I go oh great if we
need something from the backseat she can
reach it have a great mom well
Daisy's really excited because she's
never left Kansas or Missouri so this is
gonna be a really fun thing for Daisy
and I said alright you know it's her
birthday fine
I don't really know Daisy but she seems
lovely so I have a 79 year old a 65 year
old and I have not my sister-in-law that
I wanted to have my sister who's not
really present a lot so we go to Paris
said she want to go to Paris and Rome we
get to Paris we're gonna go down the
Shah sale is a the most big shopping
street that everybody's all gung-ho I
don't really give a but I'll go
along with this my sister says she walks
ahead of us and comes back and there's
two of giant Asian people they're cute
they're like you know like Ameth they're
like seven feet top five thousand twelve
I've never seen aging people this tall
and they're beautiful they look like
models and my sister comes running back
she goes that man just asked to kiss me
I go what she goes I swear to God walk
by him he'll go kiss me okay I just want
to see if it will happen so I walk by
him and he said excuse me
I said no Kate he said excuse me and my
mom and the other Daisy have caught up
and these two Asian people my sister
goes I think they're Japanese I go well
then the the tallest Japanese people
that have ever walked earth and we
should get a picture with them in an
Instagram video they're not Japanese
they're Chinese and they handed us a
laminated menu which I've like a
Friday's menu except it had purses on it
from the Louis Vuitton store
and they were Chinese nationals because
the ladies English was terrible she goes
all we need you to go by depresses in
the river time we cannot because we are
Asian we cannot buy the persons like
this is a scam like how dumb are we my
sister and my mom both tho know Kathleen
she's right because at the lake of the
ozarks in Missouri at the outlet mall
the Asians were buying too much stuff in
the Ralph Lauren star so they banned
them so what are you telling me an Asian
person can't walk in the pot well not
just ages but they started it and that's
what started it and I said I don't think
the Lake of the Ozark outlaw in Missouri
rules apply to the SHA sale is a we are
in Paris wait what is the matter with
you people
my sister goes this is always your
problem you're so cynical and you're
mean and you you you you don't you
didn't go to Catholic school long enough
you don't have a heart you're not doing
the right thing these people are being
punished because they're agents we
should do it I said how are we going to
behind the purses lady goes hi I had the
money and she opens a bag and there's
$10,000 in the bag cash
I go okay guys this this ain't enough to
show you that there's something very
wrong I'm just saying I said I also
don't think just for the record that we
look like we belong in the Louie Vuitton
store
my sister goes why why don't we look
like we belong in the loop I go well we
could start with the fact that Daisy's
sweatshirt says I love dachshunds that I
said have you guys ever been in one
there it's gonna be a purse museum
there's gonna be five purses under glass
we don't look appropriate that's an
aside this is a scam
no no you're an asshole you're mean
fine
I go okay Chinese people what are we
supposed to do clearly I've been
outvoted and we're gonna do it we're
gonna do we're gonna do whatever the
is that the lady goes are we cocky
you $10,000 you buy and she points to
for purses one no the one that caused
the most trouble was called the Papillon
I wanted to put a picture of it up
tonight but cheetahs doesn't have good
AV equipment but you can google it just
Google Louis Vuitton app Yad purse it's
a cylinder type little bag and I said
okay so we walked at the Louis Vuitton
store clearly none of us look like we
belong there there's about eight purses
under glass like their museum pieces
and my mom would she can't speak the
language of wherever she is chooses to
speak English with flair of the accent
of those people
she walked up to the counter because I
said who's gonna who's gonna commit the
crime
I'm just curious who who's gonna who's
gonna let this go down because I'm not
touching the money and I'm not touching
this Chinese lady's purse I'm not doing
my mouth was why I want to buy the purse
I go what if the money's counterfeit has
anybody thought about that my sister
goes well who cares I just want to go to
Louie Vuitton stores spent thousands of
dollars family that's the fun of it
don't you think the fun of it let's go
no I don't I don't I don't I don't see
any fun this is our afternoon and we're
bargaining with people about purses on a
laminated menu no but I'm an asshole I
know that's been established but asshole
I'm gonna go along with it so my blocks
up to the counter and points it the
first one that the lady told us to buy
because they're all twenty five hundred
dollars according to the ladies so we
have ten thousand dollars we can afford
for purses my mom points him yes it
looks at this super beautiful fridge but
she goes I would like
[Applause]
not just say that like that she goes
shut up Kathleen shut up you're cynical
I would like to buy one appeal so the
French lady I couldn't believe I thought
do we get that one or is there more in
back like I don't even know how this
works
the lady pulls the sacred purse out and
puts it on the thing it says I would
need $2,500 for you
my mom whips up the cash like it didn't
buck just cash like we're the biggest
rednecks on earth we just walked in with
cash in sacks let's say I love Parra's
like whatever she puts it down I
immediately hear there's seven security
guards in black with machine guns and I
go what who's the asshole now I can't
stop laughing my mom goes don't you
laugh at this this is serious I know I
know I said it was serious 45 minutes
ago on this street when I wanted to have
a beer at a cafe we've been looped into
this caper of enormous proportions she
goes i this is not my money
we you will follow us and they take us
to a room I go I go they're not
even Cavs
what the wait what have we done
it's illegal my dad is was a lawyer and
a judge his whole life all I heard my
whole life was say are we under arrest
and if you're not shut up and then the
other thing you say is I do not recall
and I need an attorney
I said now listen
listen mom Kate not Daisy issues from
Kansas she's excused
but you two have lived a lifetime with a
lawyer and a judge we are not under
arrest this is what do you you
aren't gonna do what they say Kathleen
we're gonna follow these people we're in
a lot of trouble okay great so we go to
the conference room or wherever we're
take it to like a mini jail type thing
in the Louie Vuitton store they have
their own jail they're rambling on and
my mom said tell them we're not
criminals you took seven years of French
speak to them I go I did take seven
years of French and here's all I can say
do you have a beer in your library
that's okay and I can only speak in the
past tense because I didn't understand
the president the futuristic that's so
whatever I say had to have already
happened or it's not gonna make any
sense these fake cops security people
it's Louie Vuitton security this is why
I'm so offended like what why am i why
are we getting busted you clearly know
what we did and you're you know pissed
off at us well you know go out on the
street and get your Chinese people
you're so angry with they said that's
the Chinese mafia and what they do is
they look for idiots clearly us for that
looks semi nice so Midwest II American
Dom we fit the mold then they have the
purses that they chose were the spring
premier debut bags they take them back
to China they mass-produced them for the
super-rich Chinese people and then they
mass-produced for everyone else so Louis
Vuitton is very angry about this and
they said we're gonna need you ladies to
take that money back to the Chinese
people on the street so we can identify
them and then we will follow them and we
will arrest them I go I bet you do need
us to do that but what do we get like a
purse or like
why am i part of your sting this is
I can walk out of here with
this money and give it back and have
nothing to do with you people like I
don't understand why you're gonna have a
79 year old from Kansas 65 year old with
no knee and we're part of your goddamn
sting I said we're also returning
without the purses so what if the
Chinese people get pissed and say you
didn't do the agreement that I'd never
agreed to but these three wackadoodles
are all in on when they said no you will
not be in any danger I said well I don't
know that I trust that but then my mom
goes no we're gonna do what they say I'm
petrified I were gonna do what they say
fine
so we walk back down the street and
there's our Chinese friends and we
walked out and we hand them the money
now I'm expecting police or something's
going to happen and my mother lecture of
what you did was wrong wrong wrong and
then she throws her Asian accent in
which is appalling you lied to us
you lied to us
bad bad bad I said stop stop speaking
stop talking where this has been a
horrible enough day so we walked away
and then my mom goes they were very
angry at what I said and we didn't get
their purses and now I'm afraid the
whole mafia knows about us but she I
could tell she can get really weirdly
upset and she said I don't feel safe
here anymore
I said safe meaning like the Shawn sale
is a or Paris France I don't feel safe
here anymore Kathleen I'm not leaving
the hotel room unless your father comes
over here which we know he won't or we
need to leave and I go are you're
serious like we're gonna yeah let's go
to Italy right now change the plans I
said fine cuz I'm not gonna put up with
this it's too much it's crazy so we go
to Rome she wants to go to the Vatican
there's a big square somewhere in Rome
it's getting dark and there's a man
selling all the knockoff purses of the
Louis Vuitton bags and she goes you know
after everything we've been through I
think for my birthday I want that bag I
said then you go get it you go ask him
how much she walks over she walks back
she goes no he wanted $60 I'm not paying
$60 I'm not paying six I'll pay 25
I said well you should have said that
she goes I don't like to negotiate so I
said I'll do it and then I realized I
was running I couldn't find him he had
gone away and I'm looking for this man
and waving money running down an alley
thinking at the moment how dumb am i I'm
literally screaming I have money I have
money and I'm alone in an alley in Italy
like but I found him and I said look I
can I will only give you $25 he goes 40
I said fine Seoul she'll never know and
I took it back and I go happy
birthday boy this is the hardest I've
worked for any present ever and for the
record it's not even real
that's the story thank you